[Música]
Sean bienvenidos a un episodio más de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro Cordero Durante los últimos días
han vuelto las escenas de tensión a
kosovo el enfrentamiento entre los
servocos o bares y los albanocos ovares
en el norte del país ha hecho que
incluso tengan que intervenir Los cascos
azules de Naciones Unidas que llevaban
desplegados en la zona desde 1999 el
motivo es la toma de posesión de
alcaldes albano kosovares en municipios
de mayorías Serbia tras unas
controversiales elecciones municipales
boicoteadas por los servocos ovares una
cuestión que ha hecho que la Unión
Europea pida repetir los comicios Pero
cuál es el contexto que vive kosovo y
Cuál es el origen de su conflicto para
entender la situación toca remontarse a
tiempos de la República federativa
socialista de yugoslavia este extinto
país se encontraba en el este de Europa
y estaba compuesto por hasta seis
repúblicas socialistas entre las que
podemos destacar eslovenia Croacia
Bosnia herzegovina y Serbia dentro de la
República socialista de Serbia había dos
provincias autogestionadas que eran boi
bodina y kosovo este territorio era
considerado por los nacionalistas
serbios como el origen de la nación
Serbia sin embargo Durante los últimos
siglos este territorio empezó a ser
ocupado por una mayoría de población
albanesa que llegó a ocupar hasta tres
cuartas partes del total de los
kosovares y que hizo que los serbios
pasaran a ser una minoría en kosovo el
inicio de los problemas comenzó a surgir
tras la muerte del dictador yugoslavo
Yoshi Bros Tito en 1980 los albanucos
ovares empezaron a reclamar que kosovo
fuera una República socialista dentro de
yugoslavia Pero estas reclamaciones
fueron duramente reprimidas y el origen
de la expansionismo del
ultranacionalismo serbio liderado por
eslogan milosevich una figura que se
encargaría de reprimir a las etnias no
serbias de yugoslavia y que sería el
principal causante de las independencias
de eslovenia Croacia Bosnia y macedonia
a inicios de la década de 1990 y que
posteriormente degenerarían en Las
Guerras yugoslavas
Durante este conflicto decenas de miles
de personas fallecieron millones fueron
desplazadas y se cometieron limpiezas
étnicas hasta que yugoslavia finalmente
desapareció
aunque kosovo no participó y siguió
formando parte de Serbia las tensiones
interétnicas se mantuvieron y explotaron
en 1998 el gobierno serbio ocupó
militarmente kosovo para eliminar a la
insurgencia albano kosovar que pedía la
autodeterminación algo que degenero en
una guerra en la que incluso intervino
la otan quienes tras diálogos fallidos
con el gobierno de milosevich decidieron
bombardear Belgrado la capital Serbia
para forzar el final del conflicto en el
año
no hemos visto señales de que tropas
serbias salgan de kosovo
ni una indicación directa de que milose
Beach apoye a una fuerza internacional
para el mantenimiento de la paz
construida en torno al mando y control
de la otan
y desde luego no hemos visto indicios de
que los refugiados vuelvan a sus hogares
por lo tanto nuestra intención es
continuar la campaña aérea e
intensificarla
el controversial bombardeo de Belgrado
causó el final del gobierno de
milosevich quien posteriormente sería
detenido y juzgado por crímenes de
guerra y genocidio por su parte en
kosovo fueron desplegados cascos azules
para mantener la paz y el territorio
pasó a tener un autogobierno hasta que
se declaró su independencia el 17 de
febrero de 2008 una autodeterminación
parcial reconocida por más de 90 países
de los 193 que forman Naciones Unidas
pero rechazada por Serbia Rusia China o
España
hoy la República de kosovo está
recibiendo el reconocimiento de la
independencia de kosovo por parte de los
países más fuertes el nuevo estado de
kosovo está obteniendo lentamente su
derecho al reconocimiento internacional
por parte de los países con poder de
decisión porque son sin embargo no todos
en kosovo reconocieron esta
Independencia una serie de poblaciones
de mayoría Serbia sobre todo
concentradas en el norte del país en la
frontera con Serbia precisamente se
negaron a reconocer al nuevo gobierno
albano kosovar y formaron una serie de
asociaciones que se encargaron de
denunciar Durante los años siguientes
una supuesta marginación con respecto a
la mayoría al vano kosovar y que además
mantuvieron una tensión bastante alta
con la nueva con el nuevo gobierno
kosovar para poner fin a esta tensión
constante el gobierno de pristina Se
comprometió en el año 2013 a reconocer a
La minoría servocoso bar y a garantizar
a estos municipios que poseen una de
unas 100.000 personas a tener un
autogobierno y cierta autonomía sin
embargo Esto no se ha cumplido y los
intentos de tomar el control de estos
municipios servocoso bares han sido
constantes en esta situación se llega al
contexto actual en el que el gobierno
kosovar impuso unas elecciones
municipales en el norte que fueron
boicoteadas por la mayoría servocoso bar
de estos municipios y aunque estas
elecciones solo tuvieron una
participación del
3,5%, el gobierno de pristina dio por
buenos los comicios Y puso a cargo a
alcaldes albano kosovares algo
intolerable para La minoría servocoso
bar una tensión que también ha sido
aprovechada por Alexander buschich el
presidente serbio para avivar el relato
nacionalista en torno a kosovo en un
momento de mala popularidad de su
gobierno un episodio más de una crisis
cíclica que parece estar lejos de
terminar mientras ninguna de las dos
partes esté dispuesta a ceder en sus
intereses con esto concluimos si quieren
conocer más historias sigan conectados a
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]